[Music]
sorry you're already taking a job as
next week
excuse me your brain excuse me would you
always says your judge hey guys welcome
back to the record where we talk about
whatever we want can you wear blue hair
next week - yeah like a difference in
would you dye your hair
Steven an ultimate reality well you
could be without your hair I've never I
haven't dyed my hair since high school I
love your natural hair
thank you very luxurious I enjoy it very
much there's a lot of Bounce I want it
this is the perfect time to tell the
break save this stuff I was gonna say
exclusive so you know we're going to
Vegas yeah okay and you guys were
talking about how like plane tickets are
kind of expensive it's Easter weekend or
in 4/20 weekend and whatever whatever
there's like yeah the plane tickets are
expensive that weekend yeah did you
check it a price hey why didn't but I
heard a lot of people were driving I
blah okay what about it okay so I
haven't driven to Vegas in a very long
time but when we used to drive to Vegas
there's this place called deep creek
that have you heard of it no ok so you
camped there
we don't have to camp there but you can
camp there it's like ten dollars and you
you set up camp at the top and then you
hiked down 45-minute hike and there's a
river and then at the top of the river
there's hot springs so it's like a beach
with a river and then like you and then
right above it is hot springs so you're
like in the jacuzzi and then you're like
oh it's kind of too hot and then you go
into the river and you're like wow
that's cool and then it's do bad it's
it's kind of like a detox it's like
really fun but we want our way back from
Vegas yeah do we have to be late here or
on the way back but I would suggest on
the way back because it feels like very
refreshed we have to be making there's a
nudist colony that sometimes they're not
a lot of people but like maybe like five
or so nudists we'll be there at a time
and you kind of get used to it because
like they're submerged in the water
usually going again they can go over
there
sure it's kind of fun it's all of us and
there's
levels already seen as dick I've seen
dunk contest I've seen his dick I
purposely don't trim if I'm gonna go to
a group setting really why because it
feels like clothes not be too free cuz
it feels like clothes you don't want
anyone to sexualize you
yeah it's there's nothing there cuz it's
just fur I never realized how uneven my
can is until I go to like one of those
naked spas yeah you walk by the mirror
and you're looking like God [ __ ] like
dark and then white and a white ass and
then dark it's like you don't see when
you go to the shower
no she's not paying attention to that oh
we've been nowhere but now we're in
public like you're more self-conscious
hmm it's really your self conscious I
mean it's still like only three percent
maybe but it's more than usual
I look like chocolate cover ice cream
what right make it sounds fun guys let's
do it we should do it on the but do we
have to leave earlier to beat the Vegas
traffic back to Ellie because it's
always crazy you would either like leave
in the morning on the day that you're
coming back yeah even the morning and it
would be like a day trip or if you
wanted to camp there you would leave
like the afternoon before set up camp
have a camping trip and then you're
already but just do a day trip yeah I
think the day trip is better than Steve
[ __ ] hates camping he does of course
oh come on you don't think you think he
would like camping loves it but he's
plugged in all the time he has to you
know he needs to be showered all the
time if if Steve could upload his brain
in a laptop I think you would into a
monster drink yeah into a monster he'd
be old monster drink with arms yeah
that's only wants to reincarnate camping
though I still wash myself though yes so
do I trust a [ __ ] yes this place
there's no showers but there's the river
and the spring that's pretty [ __ ]
good it's called deep water Creek it's
called deep creek deep creek yeah that
sounds like a porn did the nudist
bleeping out every time we're saying
this cuz then a whole bunch of people
are gonna want to go you don't know what
we can we're going like is it
I could take out the dates you could
take up well they don't know what day
we're gonna go well we're not uploading
before we're going we just don't tell
them that it's May 8th again
we don't say that yeah I don't say it's
me wait till we get both what's really
fun and then they have like this this
one part where like the hot water from
the springs is like pouring off and it's
like a shower yeah yeah do it
yeah rushing is awesome yeah we're not
bringing Tycho's Bojo perfect whatever
fall you're like man how's the baby
doing I love that dude but then when we
get a long time which is almost never
when you get alone time how many days
can you do without Tiger how come he's
touching his own dick I'm not going to a
long time without him yeah he'd do a
long time with I always think about him
I looked in our security cameras I
always look but uh these days since we
have them a lot it's nice to have a long
time oh yeah so you use yours so you got
too much tighter going on that's crazy
you feel like you have a lot cuz you
only see him like one hour a day cuz you
come home pretty late for us though I'm
converted to us oh I think so if I come
home and we have like three hours family
time and then only one hour of us it's
always 3 2 1 3 2 1 3 2 1 and you know
how robotic I am that all adds up so I'm
like [ __ ] I got 12 hours of tyka but
maybe only 3 hours of Geo oh that's cute
he was more geo time I mean who doesn't
he just turned it all around who doesn't
right how about you Geo more time with
me huh Oh Geo can't go without take it
from me that was my that was my next
guess
no I'm attached I [ __ ] like three
hours I think these two hours how you
gonna survive in Vegas yeah I mean I'll
be with you guys so it'll be fun like
I'll coffee Tigers yeah I'll constantly
be checking but I'll try to be in the
moment with you guys but then once we're
not I'm not in the moment with you guys
I'm gonna be like on the [ __ ] thing
like you know what I wish I wish the
security cams had like smell-o-vision to
see smells good yeah stinky smells good
its pristine I could bite your arm
I could slap the camera away yeah I'm
not gonna be there how come you're not
going on the trip man know what happens
every time contracted here - huh you
didn't come with us last time I did yeah
Yeti was there not the last time yeah he
was Michael Jackson yes I had the
Polaroids that we took photos of with
you in it you son of a [ __ ] I remember
oh you're right because you kept going
away with Mary all like when is he
gambling with us no I just remember you
guys waking up early and exercising and
then I went to the gym yeah we did and
you guys caught me during my hook that's
why I just started losing weight
remember so I was very dedicated you
were oh your birthday they saying to you
in the I was drunk yeah yeah and the
girl had a really good voice yeah she
did see you see but you want to miss
that again I don't want to yeah you do
where are you doing something I think
we're going to be in Houston wait so
your birthday's coming up yeah it's
gonna be the Ares March March 30th what
the [ __ ] did you have to think about huh
you like it smart what I don't remember
mine either
you know I almost never remember I
always think about it Oh birthday's
coming up - yeah along with us data dead
Joe 12 yeah we're all really close dude
yeah don't you wait yeah that's true
kisses November 29th yeah
dude let's just celebrate our birthday
together because my parents are coming
on my daughter Vegas do be careful
you stop hey you should go to Vegas do I
send foods in Vegas you know that much
ahead of time when you're going I do
didn't get a notice but you can't do the
podcast the day before
interesting Oh David you in trouble
David David in trouble
David in trouble I've already explained
this to you before I don't care
explain it to the public whatever
happened a couple of times is that we
get these dates ahead of time right but
sometimes they want to shoot the day
before yeah if it's good good then I but
then we'll fly out on a Friday then I
could shoot on a Thursday but just today
which is when we shoot cheeky news yeah
so I want to make sure that is cemented
at least that I know that I'm not going
on a Thursday which will be about a few
days before so for this either way I'm
gonna be gone that whole weekend Davis
said if he misses the podcast appearance
on our podcast the next week that Hugh
will die
it'll be the third time that you may
know actually it would be the second
time the first time I just completely
ignored the email yeah yeah she don't
email to be on the quizzes like hello
thanks David
yeah see when I saw you now I realized
it was you I was like dude it's
literally the first word of the email
yeah it could have been anybody though
who spells Nicky with two K's huh
anyways Vegas is great you come you
won't know you should you know what I
realized - wait are you going to Japan I
am going to Japan oh girl serious I am
going to Japan you know I realized too
recently so this is joint out in Beijing
District one they do this lot right and
Tim and I were talking about somebody
that we know that says that they didn't
like the lobster flood they said it
wasn't good and this person does like
like mukbang stuff for a living from now
on that person's taste buds are trash to
me really why do we know this song
because it's bonk cuz it's actually
really good maybe they got lobster so
for them I guess like what they were
thinking was with the properly I want to
be more Lobster I wanted all this other
stuff I was like yo it tastes good like
the portions are good too they also have
like this oxtail fried rice thing which
is delicious sounds fun shoutouts to you
guys I'm putting you stuck in delicious
yeah baby we'll go check it out we're
out there without you yeah the cocktails
are [ __ ] Bob - I like girls yeah
Vegas that's a big foodie scene it's
just biggest oh yeah is that place where
if it's successful somewhere else in the
in the country there's gonna go there
yeah right
if you
an Eiffel Tower you're gonna go to Vegas
Statue of Liberty
you'll be make the architecture all over
the world oh this succeeded here okay
are you guys gonna do the buffet thing
of course you know what we're paying for
the buffets all right but it's at the
Rio in the blodger oh yeah I know the
seafood buffet remember we went yeah
yeah the Bellagio one's good too
the winners good too yeah but it'sit's
because it's we have shows scheduled ah
Hotel so I thought it was just easier to
do that so where's the one they have
prime rib there huh they all feel the
same to me the win is good yeah but you
know I don't know it's been a while
since I did the buffet thing so I miss
it but every single time like you had to
do the buffet you had to go to the beach
I mean not the beach the pool area the
day club or whatever you have to go put
club and even though you don't like it
you just like claustrophobic in there I
just be ample yeah I love gambling when
I first started going and I was like 21
I try to do all that stuff and I'm like
well I had no money right and then you
go back and then you finally get to do
it you're like this is it that's it you
know like this is nothing oh the all
this stuff and I actually enjoy all of
grandpas stuff yeah remember the Gordon
Ramsay burger place that we went to I
didn't go there but you guys did yes I
did yeah we did was i sleeping no you
would oh wait I don't remember I
remember that would be joy oh I was
there too Oh was it that time we win
that I threw up I had a yeah it was
burgers did you like it or do you though
so right so so I did a video on it right
and I was just saying like this wasn't a
good burger
let's do Gordon Ramsay's fans are
[ __ ] fanatics they're like what the
[ __ ] do you know about a good burger and
I was like did you even read the reviews
on the place is trash but I saw him at
the office oh yeah our office I saw him
he was filming or something right didn't
you say something yeah I saw him that's
so cool see would have flipped out he
loves Gordon Ramsay he always does
Gordon Ramsay impressions on tasty
Tuesday that's time Gordon Ramsay's face
looks like a scrotum it's worse in
person oh really no makeup on how close
were you to him ladies on maybe from
like me to G or a little bit further
yeah cuz I was in my car and I was
pulling up and then me and power like
looking at each other like that's this
guy well his outfit was hideous yeah
we had like a tan jumpsuit that was
super flamboyant it looked like a pimp
would wear and then yeah it was like one
of those fleece like you know like one
are me an Armenian gangster you know
like it was a tracksuit kind of thing
but it was like fleece like oh I would
never picture of Gordon Ramsay need that
right right and in like are you sure I
was Gordon Ramsay well I was thinking
that and he goes is that Gordon Ramsay
and I'm like oh [ __ ] that is and as soon
as we locked eyes he like looks down
like that like aw [ __ ] fans he was with
the entourage and everything in like a
[ __ ] like top-notch Range Rover and
stuff so I was so offended he was like
awesome being a noise like the I'm
[ __ ] famous to jackass alright I'm
doing I'm doing this to you [ __ ] David
so fans I would run up to him and go
like this so he knows that I don't want
him to notice yeah he's only a
one-person guide no please stop stop
stop no pictures please yourself yeah
stop stop stop I have the photos out
stop stop you know what's surprisingly
good the pizza Wolfgang Puck's you guys
ever got that no it's [ __ ] bomb did
you get that I feel like if you're gonna
go to Wolfgang Puck's bucks why would
you get pizza we we all should you get
well like I would get whatever their
star thing another menu I guess we
before UFC fight we ate there and we got
our star stuff and all stuff was really
good remember with my ate with James oh
yeah yeah eat there and then me being
the fat guy that I am yeah I ain't gonna
[ __ ] finish I'm gonna fill me up I
got to get a pizza cuz I also heard of
David Chang talking about his pizza and
how it's really good and I ate I'm like
dad this is really good and then before
a funk concert last month I confirmed it
because there's a wolfgang positive
early life yeah it was really really
good haven't even stepped foot inside of
core game get a pizza if you do it's so
good you know what blows my mind about
food is that it's just like any other
art right but then you need it to
survive because taste is just it's a
cents just like anything else there's
different perspectives best height to
that right so like what's good is really
subjective yeah but what people consider
to be good and all that blows my
freaking mind of why they think
something is good yeah it depends on
what the experience you want to buy so
like some people love like elitist type
of lifestyles so anything if it's elite
it's like all automatically get what
blows my mind is that when you taste the
ingredient a store like oh this is oh
you don't have a develop palate
yeah but this is bad like it's a palette
it's not elite can't you tell that's not
that's not prime or like you know like I
don't know yeah cuz you could mask it by
making it look beautiful yeah I mean
that's for anything though cuz even how
equipment is everything clothing
clothing it's like people can say
arguably like Jordan comes out people
will like it just because something is
new versus seeing it like respect
respect because of the novelty right
yeah so it's like I'll say some stuff
like like for example like I like
cameras right for me if it looks good it
looks good and cameras are more for me
if it works with what you're doing and
it's perfect for you it's not to say
that it's better just because of the
stats of it right but then I like I had
like a conversation with a friend of
mine he goes like okay well I really
liked it was like it was a new
mirrorless camera that came out and I
looked at for frame for frame I was like
this doesn't look good right and he goes
we talked about it's new it's newer than
your camera it's like that doesn't mean
that it looks better than right it's
still a shittier [ __ ] camera but just
because for him new means better right
for him he's stuck on that and so I had
to fight a YouTube video spec for spec
put it out like do you see now he goes
oh I guess it's like matte books like
MacBook Pros are super expensive yeah
but if you're used to like for example I
don't know anything about computers and
I'm used to using a MacBook Pro to edit
to edit videos and to do airdrop and all
that stuff and I know that there's more
powerful computers out there I'm just
not used to them so I'll pay more even
though yeah but it's because from my
experience like this is the best thing
for my experience I'm used to it I wish
it wasn't that expensive I don't I like
my 2013 MacBook Pro way more than my
2018 one that I just bought because I
just like the way it functioned better
people can literally convince themselves
of anything yeah well you're also not
going
I'll say this is the best and everything
else but it's all perspective like what
you want out of it ray exactly it's the
best lot power and GPU and all that
stuff then you're gonna go get a PC and
you don't care like what it looks like
or if it can connect to your phone or
whatever but if you want like more like
just efficiency with workflow then
that's the one for you that it's the
best for you but it's funny because
people will argue about that all the
time they'll be like you're just an
Apple fanboy and and the fanboys are
like no it's actually better because
I've been like oh that's serious cuz
here like we [ __ ] around with it but
we're not even so people are so serious
about it and I'm like no thank you
I don't think any of us your [ __ ]
cares like well we make fun of Android
users oh yeah they're in there like it's
super real yeah I'm like no we don't
really give a [ __ ] bro but then I feel
like younger people for sure probably
get like made fun of because I should
like that maybe or maybe that's what
it's but when we do it we're joking
around like what the [ __ ] really cares
yeah we were serious guys I've been
dividing these people in my head hating
David because he got this phone I
thought we were like nothing how [ __ ]
dare you let me write a note about your
hate when the group text turned to green
I know I and then when you want to laugh
or like something yesterday so one other
decision liked this every time I like
something or thumbs it up I think of
your mom like she was the only Android
user and so all of us when we like a
comment it because it she has her
Android it writes it out like Nikki
laughed at Melanie's photo or whatever
and she thought we were all writing it
so she goes laughed at oh my god dude
that's so funny she put lol and she put
a comment in there too and I'm like you
wrote that and she's like no I did it to
try to backtrack that's even funnier I'm
not old we're gonna call me with me you
can't do that if you like a comment you
know what I like to do on Android
Android has some of the janky little
gifs and I'll just send it just to
[ __ ] make fun of myself it's like
this dog that goes okay
and is the ugliest [ __ ] cartoon
drawing I've ever seen in my life
and I'm like this is the ugliest thing
I've ever seen and I'm gonna send out
just to piss people off Android all the
way do emojis come out different for you
yeah you're smiley you know weird
they're like a little bit more three two
years yeah they're way more 3d
really you look cool bootleg huh
[Music]